[Music]
Logan and I connected on a significant
level early on actress Chloe Bennet gets
candid about her boyfriend YouTube star
Logan Paul in my opinion friends
sometimes make us touch buddies earlier
this year Logan publicly thanked Khloe
for sticking by him amid his
controversial antics people make
mistakes and if you can't have room to
grow from a mistake and if you can't
forgive people despite changing I don't
think really we have anything I think I
think growth comes from making mistakes
I don't I've never known anyone who's
grown just from being perfect et spoke
with Chloe at the LA premiere of crazy
rich Asians I'm really excited to
support people like Randall and
Constance and and really just have a
movie that represents my people and she
dished what's next for her I just
started season six of agents of shields
we're shooting then you can tease
absolutely nothing on word to describe
it it's um it's more Game of Thrones
wait will we see valley girl is valley
girl gonna I don't know any and valley
girl information but I I have seen it
and it's really good and I hope everyone
gets to see it
[Applause]
[Music]